Speaker 1: Trump lawyer, olina haba.
Is now making the new claim that Nancy
Pelosi orchestrated the January six,
2021 Trump riots at the U.S. Capitol.
How is that possible? How is it possible
that that's what she did? Well, here she is,
Alina Harbor, explaining it herself. And there
are two basic, fundamental, important claims
that underlie this idea. They've both been
debunked and we're going to get to them, but
understand that they don't even know what to say
anymore. And so now it's forget about Trump didn't
incite the riots. Nancy Pelosi orchestrated them.
Speaker 3: I don't need it. Get them in place. He
was concerned himself. He said, let's get extra
military. We will give you people to come in
and to make sure that the Capitol is safe. No,
no, no. I don't want it. Well, now we see why,
Eric. We see why. Because it was it was
orchestrated because she said this is her moment.
This is our moment. No, it's not your moment.
Speaker 1: Okay, so there's two claims there.
And these are claims that they've repeated
many times. The first claim is Trump asked
for 10,000 National Guard troops, which would
have prevented the riots. That's claim one. Okay,
this is how we actually figure stuff out. Okay.
The first claim is Trump says, I asked for 10,000
troops. They didn't give them to me. The second
claim that's being made is Nancy Pelosi rejected
the 10,000 troops coming to Washington, D.C. to
prevent the riot. So two claims Trump requested.
Nancy Pelosi rejected. Neither one of them is
true. The first one is the Trump claim. Okay.
There is no evidence that Trump made that request.
Now, if you want to be endlessly skeptical,
you can always say, Is it possible Trump requested
the troops and the request was thrown in the trash
in order for there to be no evidence? You can
always do that. But the point here is there is
no evidence of written telecommunications. People
on the other end of the requests saying, yeah,
I got we got that request from the Trump White
House for the National Guard troops. PolitiFact
has explored this and has determined that it
is false. They have found no such evidence.
The second claim is that Nancy Pelosi rejected
the troops. Sean HANNITY has been saying it for
a very long time and so have others. Again,
there is no evidence that Nancy Pelosi,
Chuck Schumer or anyone else rejected the request
for the 10,000 or sometimes it's 20,000 troops
that are mentioned. Now, of course, if there's no
evidence that the request was ever made, there's
no request to reject either. And that's another
layer to this thing that's important to mention.
I would love it if Olena Haba made some of these
claims under oath. I don't think that's going
to happen. And remember that Donald Trump's TV
lawyers and his court lawyers tend to be different
people. We heard from Michael Cohen about how that
works, and I don't expect to actually see Alina,
have him make any of these claims under oath. But
every single one of these claims has been soundly
rejected and or there is simply no evidence for
it whatsoever one way or the other, because it
doesn't appear that such a request was ever made.
They'll keep telling the lie, and we have to
keep reminding them. There's just no evidence.
You're just saying that you're making that up.